Thanks, Kevin.
We are very pleased with the company's third quarter.
The strong financial performance is a result of having the right products...
...at the right cost at the right time for a recovering global economy.
The strength in our business remains primarily consumer driven...
...with broad-based demand across all geographies.
Our mobile business had a particularly strong quarter.
In fact, we saw the sequential unit growth rate of notebook processors and chipsets...
...actually exceed the growth rate of Atom processors and chipsets.
While Atom and netbooks are important growth drivers for us,...
...our traditional notebook business remains one of the primary drivers of revenue growth...
...and we expect that to continue in the future.